Apple's iPhone 14 event is happening in
just two weeks on September 7th where
they'll be revealing the entire iPhone
14 lineup which is gonna be drastically
different from the lineup we have today
especially in terms of the new features
and thankfully the very reliable Apple
leaker Ross young who is almost never
wrong has just confirmed the exact
iPhone lineup that we should be
expecting and this is important because
we've recently had some confusion
surrounding the iPhone 14 with some
leaks contradicting each other in big
ways so before I get into explaining
every little difference between the
iPhone 14 models that Ross young
confirmed we've got to put this new
rumor to bed 91 mobiles recently came
out with some exclusive information from
Apple's partners and they showed off the
iPhone 14 lineup including the iPhone 14
mini which goes against everything we've
been hearing about the lineup for the
past few months that have been saying
that Apple will no longer be making the
Mini version of the iPhone and that's of
course because the 13 mini has had
terrible sales like in the March quarter
when only three percent of us iPhone
sales were 13 mini models so Mac Rumors
reported that the sketchy iPhone 14 mini
leak was likely wrong and then finally
91 mobiles came out and admitted that
the 14 mini is not coming and there's
going to be a Max size model in its
place and of course months ago Ming
chukwo who was very reliable let us know
that the mini is going away for good so
we can trust in that but then we got
some more leaks about the new model
being named the 14 plus making things
confusing again but finally Ross young
came out and confirmed the truth by
revealing the panel shipments uh I'm
kind of filming I know you we got an ad
spot these two bad reviews been going
down they're not paying as much we got
to pay the bills rage Shadow Legends yep
it's a raid ad
rage Shadow Legends is the first game to
bring a true console level experience to
your phone and of course PC with
hundreds of equippable artifacts and
over 600 Champions you can choose to
dominate the Doom Tower Dungeons and all
of the bosses including the Hydra Clan
boss and this month raids got a bunch of
special events and activities like Forge
past season 3 with rewards like a
limited edition artifact set Champions
like the Ultimate Death Knight who's now
a legendary champion and awesome skins
for the incredible Madame saris so this
is the best time to get started with
raid today and if you click my link in
the description or scan the QR code
you'll get unique bonuses worth 30
dollars including verges a free epic
Champion so click that link and I'll see
you in the game alright back to the
video Ross young revealed the panel
shipments to his five dollar a month
super followers which I am so thankfully
he gave me permission to share One
exclusive tweet with you guys as you
guys can see right here we have four
models the 14 the 14 Max the 14 pro and
the 14 pro Max with that model getting a
28 share of panel shipments and then the
brand new 14 Max getting the least at 19
which means Apple doesn't expect it to
be as popular as the rest but at least
we do know there's no mini there's no
plus it's the 14 Max and now with that
said let me finally explain all of the
differences between all four of the
iPhone 14 models that we're getting this
year because there are some major
differences here you can see the actual
moldings the metal moldings that some
suppliers use to create their cases and
right here you can see the differences
we have the 14 6.7 inch which is the max
on the left then we have the pro Max
also 6.7 inch then we have the regular
6.1 inch pro and then the red regular 14
6.1 inch model now some differences you
can see is first of all the camera bumps
we have huge bumps on these Pro Models
and we do have three cameras instead of
just two on the others but other than
that there's not a big difference at all
and you can actually see the glass
panels on the back that are painted and
look really really nice you got 14 14
pro 14 Max not plus and then 14 pro Max
I mean this looks sick now we also have
some differences on the front as well
because the glass panels leaked so right
here on the left you see the 14 pro Max
then the 14 Max the pro and the regular
14 and the biggest difference you see is
that the regular models are continuing
to have the notch as you can see right
here but we have multiple changes for
the new Pro Models first of all the
notch is gone we have this dual hole
punch camera system with the pill plus
the circular hole so that's really nice
it's going to look really clean in my
opinion not only that but the bezels are
thinner as you can see compared to the
regular models and that speaker Grille
is super super thin you can see right
there at the top compared to the thicker
speaker Grille enclosure right there now
moving on to some of the other changes
the new iPhone 14 models are going to be
having better battery life in general
because of a new 5G chip that's
qualcomm's Snapdragon
x65 so that's going to be nice and
they're also expected to have Wi-Fi 6E
across the board for the whole iPhone 14
lineup however the Pro Models this year
are going to have some huge improvements
and changes first of all we might get
256 gigs of Base storage on the Pro
Models compared to 128 for the regular
14s on top of that all iPhone 14 models
including the regulars and the pros are
getting a huge front facing selfie
camera upgrade now it's going to have
autofocus and it's going to have an F
1.9 aperture so there's going to be a
little bit more blur and it could look a
bit sharper and improved low light as
well and now Mac Rumors made this
awesome article showing off the camera
upgrades for all of the iPhone 14 models
compared to the 13s as you can see for
the regular 14s the wide camera is not
changing at all but then when we go to
the ultra wide they're going to an F 1.5
aperture and with autofocus compared to
F 2.4 without autofocus and of course we
have the front facing camera upgrade as
well that I already talked about and now
the big changes are coming to the Pro
Models as you can see the main camera is
going from 12 to 48 megapixels yes
that's going to be a huge difference
with pixel bidding to bring that 48 down
to 12 for kind of like low light photos
it's also going to have a seven element
telephoto lens for the telephoto but not
any other big changes is and it's going
to support 8K video recording which is
huge going from 4K to 8K that's a
massive difference I think it's going to
look beautiful and of course we have the
front facing camera upgrade with auto
focus now moving on the crazening is
going to be the camera bump as you can
see somebody got the dummy model and
look at that crazy 14 pro Max camera
bump it is massive compared to the
current one which people already think
is huge and that's because Apple has to
make the actual lens glass longer and
bigger to accommodate the bigger sensor
that's required for that 8K video with
the 48 megapixel so that is absolutely
insane now shrimp Apple Pro also shared
some of the 14 pro Max cads and as you
can see you see the super thin speaker
enclosure which is actually around three
times Slimmer than the current one you
see the Dual hole punch looks really
nice you see it from the sides this was
actually the cad that confirmed that
we're not getting the flat back you see
that huge camera bump once again I mean
this is massive now with that 8K video
with the 48 megapixel camera I do
believe that the Pro Models are going to
be getting USB 3.0 lightning connectors
so it's going to transfer stuff a lot
faster which I think is going to be a
really nice bonus now on top of that the
Pro Models are the only ones getting the
new a16 ship while the regular 14s are
sticking to the a15 once again which is
a little bit disappointing but it's not
that big of a deal I guess Apple really
wants you to go for the Pro Models
obviously and the 14 pro models are
gonna have six gigs of even faster Ram
than what the regular 14s get it's going
to be LP ddr5 compared to the regular
ones getting 4X now on top of that it's
been rumored that apple is working on
Vapor chamber cooling for these iPhone
14 models now I'm not sure if it's going
to be the entire lineup or just the pros
but this is going to be huge in terms of
improving the performance without Apple
even having to make that big of changes
for the a16 ship now on top of that the
display differences are huge with the
Pro Models getting 120 hertz Pro motion
which is super fluid and according to
rumors the regular 14s are not getting
promotion at all and even better this
year's promotion will be upgraded and
it's going to go down to 1 Hertz refresh
rate which is going to allow Apple to
basically enable the new always on
display feature which is huge and that
again is only coming to the Pro Models
and now because of all those changes
going to the Pro Models this year we are
expected to get a 100 price increase for
the pro and pro Max compared to last
year while the iPhone 14 stays the same
at likely eight hundred dollars and then
the 14 Max should be around 900 dollars
which I actually predicted back in
December of last year you can see 7.99
for the 14 8.99 for the 14 Max 10.99 for
the 14 pro and 11.99 for the 14 pro Max
and I honestly think it's going to be
worth it I'm going to be going for that
Pro Max model this year so if you're
planning on upgrading this year let me
know which model you're getting down in
the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign